- Today in this video,
I will share with you what the jobs are
that in 2030 will be in very high demand.
And also what the jobs
are that in the future
likely will not be
needed that much anymore.
And all of this is not just
based on my gut feeling,
but it's based on a study
from Boston Consulting Group called
the Future of Jobs in the Era of AI.
So, let's look into it.
Let's first better
understand their methodology.
Indeed, they're looking at two factors,
workforce demand and workforce supply.
Let's start with the latter.
So, for the workforce supply,
they're looking at graduates
from education system, from university.
They're looking at migration
and at retirement rate.
And for the workforce demand,
they're looking at technology advancement,
advancements in artificial intelligence.
They look at efficiency
increases that can be expected
in the different industries.
And they also look at the effect of COVID,
and they specifically
are modeling the effects
of all these factors,
workforce supply and demand
until 2030.
And the first main, maybe
counterintuitive, takeaway
is that, contrary to popular
demand, actually, in 2030,
it's not the case that
AI eats up all the jobs,
but actually, there will be
a shortfall of the workforce.
So there are not enough people
that actually are needed
for the jobs net overall,
the different job categories.
This is 6.7 million people
that are missing in the US
and 1.3 million people that
are missing in Germany.
So let's start with the US.
What are the job families with
the highest demand in 2030
according to Boston Consulting Group?
And I will first talk about job families,
and later in this video, at the end,
also share some very,
very specific positions
in these families that will be missing.
Let's start with number five.
And these are roles in
architecture and engineering.
Number four is business
and financial operations.
So, professionals working
in business roles,
and specifically in finance roles.
I trust this is good news
for all of us consultants,
who surely usually are
qualitatively inclined,
have a certain analytical understanding,
which definitely will be helpful
for these types of careers.
Next is healthcare practitioners
and technical support.
I also believe that this is no surprise.
All of these things will
not just be replaced by AI
and, surely, with our aging society,
the need for healthcare will increase.
Next is management,
white collar management
leadership roles.
This I found to be
actually quite interesting,
because this is an area where I often hear
that AI will replace all these positions.
Apparently, it's not so much the case,
at least not until 2030.
Last, but not least, by far
the most significant demand,
even twice the magnitude of, for instance,
management, is computer and mathematics.
So, likely, these are
the software engineers,
the professionals potentially
developing all these systems
of the future, the AI, that then,
maybe or maybe not might
replace any of these jobs.
Surely, these people will be needed.
There's a career that will
require quite formal education.
So, if you are willing
to invest in yourself
and inclined for these
types of topics, go ahead.
But now let's look at the
other side of the matter.
What are the positions we
actually will have too many people
working with these types of
qualifications in the future,
and here on number three,
it's transportation and material moving.
So, sure they can very much understand
why these things might be
automated in the future.
Many trains might drive
without train drivers.
Cars will drive without drivers.
So, many people operating
these types of vehicles
will likely not be needed
anymore in the future.
Number two of the positions
with the most significant
workforce surplus
is actually food preparation and service.
So, apparently, these types
of roles are expected to be
much more automated as well, potential,
so the demand for them declining.
Trust that makes sense also
in the light of food delivery,
quick food delivery
services, and on number one,
the role that in the US will
be most likely not needed,
at least not to the extent
as right now in the future
is office and administrative support.
So, I think you have the takeaways
that these are the more
simple business roles,
the support type of business roles
that maybe don't really require
this high level of qualification
as, for instance, the
management leadership roles,
also the business operations,
finance roles we just talked about.
So, yes, if you work in business
and your qualifications are not that high,
you're not really specialized,
not really experienced,
this might be a problem.
This is a job family that
will be at risk in the future.
And let's now switch to
Germany, and surprising,
or maybe not surprising,
the jobs that will be
in high demand are actually
quite similar than in the US.
The numbers of course, a
bit different, a bit smaller
due to the lower population in Germany.
There's one notice of
an exception, though,
and this is that people working
in educational instruction
and library will be needed.
So, education professionals
are in quite demand in Germany.
They seem to be missing in the future.
If we look at the job families
where there will actually
be a workforce surplus in the future,
I think it's pretty
interesting that number three,
we find construction and extraction.
The common narrative,
at least in Germany is
that actually there is a
big lag of qualified people
working in these sectors.
Apparently, here, the experts
of Boston Consulting Group
are predicting that this
will change in the future.
Office and administrative
support we just talked about.
Interestingly enough, for
number one is production,
where they're expected to
be more people available
in the workforce that are actually needed.
Also this, I think quite
interesting, in Germany
there's a lot of talk about these people
actually being in demand and missing,
about a need for these
qualified blue collar workers.
Apparently, at least in the future,
this might not be the case anymore,
largely, of course, likely
also due to automation.
Now, the study from
Boston Consulting Group
even went one step further
because now they're double clicked to into
these job families to really
discern the tangible positions
that likely will be in demand
or not that much in demand
in the future.
Now, let me share the top five positions
for the US and for Germany.
On number five, it's engineers.
I don't think it's that surprising,
given the other figures that we just saw.
On number four, it's medical doctors.
I think these also very much
in line with what we just saw.
On number three, business
operations specialists,
and on number two, and this is, I think,
what was quite interesting,
senior executives,
really senior leaders
of large organizations.
This is what will be in
high demand in the US,
only followed by on number
one, computer occupations.
And if you look at the
figures for Germany,
it's more or less the same story,
only with teachers stepping
in, actually, on number three.
So, what does this mean for us?
What does this mean for you?
Given that I know that at
least a good portion of you
have a professional
background in consulting,
I think roles like these,
so, senior executives and
business operations specialists,
are roles that you will
be very well equipped
after you've spent a
couple of years working
for one of the leading
consulting firms like McKinsey,
BCG, Bain, and the likes.
So, I think this is
actually quite good news,
but now, you let me know.
What is your perception on this topic?
Let me know in the comments
about your opinion.
I would very much appreciate your view.
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
or just throw the like
button for YouTube algorithm
and subscribe to the channel.
As always big, big, thanks for
the members of the channel.
Thank you for your contributions.
My name is Heinrich.
I release weekly videos
here on the channel.
So, see you again next week.